going from one football talk to another
football talk
we have
someone who
well didn't really know about football
but she won a whole football data
hackathon which is already impressive
enough
but perhaps more impressive is that she
is a jeep wrangler owner
and a thrift store power shopper
so
please everyone welcome asama
oh man
hi everyone i hope you can hear me uh
it's a pleasure to be here obviously i
wish i could see you all in person but
it is what it is um so i'm here to talk
about
my team and i's process through the 2021
nfl big data bowl
and so yeah let's get into it
so to paint the picture a little bit um
you know
the extent of my football knowledge was
really that it was a game comprised of
very large adult men who bulldoze one
another
for four quarters and the point is to
score a touchdown
or prevent them
and then there's things like fourth
downs which are hysterical because
people get really mad about their team's
decisions
at that point so that was really
the extent of it and being in the middle
of a pandemic
having really nothing to do with my free
time i'm like okay yeah let's let's get
into this american terrorist tradition
with no knowledge of it i'm like it's
it's gonna be fine i'll look at the data
do some eda i'll be able to scrap
something up together
um
i was pleasantly surprised that one
cannot in fact do that
uh
first of all the size is quite
overwhelming all the different events
as well
apologies for the blurry picture but i
think you can gain an understanding of
just how intense this was
for me
and i quickly realized that i needed to
get a team together hopefully with
people
that have a little bit more football
knowledge than i did
and then being who i am you know i was
hoping this was going to be a cute
little quarantine hobby
but being who i am in aries i'm like you
know what no no i want to win this thing
and given the theme of this con of this
hackathon it was
the topic was defense
and you know anyone who works in sports
will tell you defense is famously hard
to quantify
so i knew that with my team it just
wasn't going to be enough we needed to
maybe talk to a subject matter expert uh
maybe a coach so i started digging into
twitter and just seeing if there were
any active
nfl coaches
um and i fell upon the wonderful the one
and only mr wade phillips a championship
winning nfl coach who also was a
defensive coach
so once again me being who i am i
decided to cold dm him on a random
november wednesday night
um i was like hey i'm awesome i'm
participating in this thing i would love
like 30 minutes your time um
yeah and he was like sure
so
we we met him we got some really good
pointers on where to take our analysis
and then the work began
so in terms of our setup
this will be very familiar to all of us
who have continued to work during this
pandemic we were all our programmers so
we made sure to get up and running with
the latest version of r and use the pack
package
to
get all the packages we needed and to
upgrade them
github of course for collaboration that
was a consideration from the get-go
given that we were all in different
geographical areas and collaboration was
going to be of the essence
zoom for regular
check-ins and deep dives
and slack for quick communications
and code troubleshooting
so once we got our our setup you know
the the first and main consideration was
the data
so
i knew going in that this was going to
be pretty big data you know
on the on the kaggle page they had said
that this is an entire season's worth of
data and not only that it's tracking
data so that has the
x and y locations of every player
and the ball
10 times per second so we're getting
real real granular here and i decided to
just
bind all those 17 weeks worth of data
and it came to be about three gigabytes
and i'm like well because we're going to
be working with github how do i get this
data up
i had never pushed anything that big on
to github also i come from healthcare so
that's like a big no-no to ever push
data onto there
but i'm like you know what let me just
try and github had something to say and
the answer was hell no because our limit
is a hundred megabytes
um so i'm like
well okay uh i guess it's time to get
into some compression let's see what's
out there so i did some very
unscientific experimentation
with rda rds fst parque tsv
just things i've like never even heard
of and turns out that parquet or parquet
has overall the best compression
and the fastest read in time so shout
out to the arrow developers who may be
in attendance
you guys are the bomb um but then it
still wasn't enough i got it down to
about 200 ish megabytes but that's still
double
github's free size limit of course
there's get large file storage
but me being me and a goodwill power
shopper i hate spending money needlessly
so i decided to continue being
stubborn and try to find alternative
ways to get my data up on there and
turns out because the rstats community
literally thinks of everything
uh the r open side
developers have created the piggyback
package which is a workaround to get
data files up to two gigabytes per file
onto your github repo and the way it
works is that
these files are not handled by git in
any way
they just get on there by being tagged
as a github release
and once it's up there you can read it
in pretty easily with just like one line
of code
so that was that the data was taken care
of it's now in our github repo so it was
time to move on to the next stage of our
project
which is eda and future engineering and
we've gone over those with the
presentations um
so far caitlyn did a fantastic job just
laying out what eda
is and and how useful it is
but
um i would like to just take a moment to
talk about how tidyverse and other
packages have really
really been tremendously useful for us
in wrangling this
very large and quite complex spatial
temporal data set
many of these are
very familiar we're very familiar with
many of these but just a quick shout out
to the tibble package which goes a bit
underrated because it's well integrated
in literally every single one of these
but you know tibbles are a fantastic way
to just quickly inspect
your your outputs and
um they're also quote-unquote like they
complain more so if there's errors
it will tell you about it pretty early
on and that was important because our
project at the end ended up being
thousands of lines of code long with
certain scripts sourcing other scripts
so you know tibbles were really useful
in that error alerting functionality
because it helped us avoid just error
debugging nightmares
per special shout out to purr not
because i'm just a cat person but really
per
did a lot of work in helping us be
efficient
in applying functions over vectors and
lists it's cousin fur which helped us
gain even more speed efficiencies
skimar from the our open side community
really useful in getting quick summary
statistics shout out to janitor for
cleaning and quick frequency tables
lubridae
the greatest of all time
and this package memoize or momoys or
however you say it but this is a package
we first found out about through the
advanced r book
and
what it does is it caches function calls
so what that means is if it has
previously seen a set of inputs it will
return the previously computed output so
that's a mouthful just to say that if
you have very expensive functions
then certainly look into this package
because it will help make everything
faster so shout out to the memoirs
package and the advanced our book for
opening our eyes to many ways in which
we can make our code run faster and more
efficiently
so after the eda and the feature
engineering stage we got into the
modeling
we decided to go with xg boost and bart
bart standing for bayesian additive
regression trees these are
models are very popular in sports and
many other industries because they do
really well
with large data sets they do well with
data sets containing heterogeneous
features
they handle interaction effects with
minimal involvement from the analyst and
they have shown to have
superior predictive performance
we also use tidy models but more for the
data pre-processing steps
and this was a choice because we were in
a time pinch and we had experience
fitting models with xg boost and bart
but i think if we were to do it again i
think we would want a tidy model's
pipeline from end to end
just because tidy models is streamlined
there's
less guesswork involved and once you
invest that time up front to get
acquainted with the grammar
then it pays off
in terms of iterations and modeling is
inherently an inter iterative process
it also
tidy models as the name suggests is
part of the tidy verse so you get also
all the the benefits of functions and
pipe ability and tibbles
and actually just a side anecdote
it was quite difficult sometimes
wrangling the outputs of these
models for further manipulation like
data visualizations or feeding it into
other
packages for model interpretability but
if we had
done our entire
process with tidy models all the tidy
model outputs are tibbles and tibbles
are very malleable so
definitely a little lesson learned there
and then once our modeling was done it
was time to start thinking about
visualization and presentation now
visualization was always a part of all
the other steps i i talked about but for
this competition
specifically it really stressed the
quality of the submission so we knew we
had to step up our game there
of course given that our entire pipeline
was
tidy verse we made heavy use of gg plot
2 but really the magic i think was when
we paired it with gg animate which
allows you to animate your graphs so
it's definitely a powerful technique it
can also be misused i know certainly
that when i get exposed to like a new
technique i like want to use it on
everything ever and it's
with animation it can be distracting and
also not entirely justified so we made
sure to really convince ourselves that
this was a value add to our graphics and
given the context of the data that we're
working on which is spatial temporal
then it made a lot of sense to make use
of animation
for the purposes of really
giving the
audience time to digest what is going on
in a way that is not
overwhelming given how busy these graphs
are um we packed a lot in here uh given
just the restrictions of the competition
i think they kept it at like five
visualizations so because we packed a
lot in here animation uh was definitely
very justified here
another key player in our visualization
roster was the gt package which i
believe stands for grammar of tables so
because our pipeline once again entirely
tidy verse this was just able to plug
right in
to to our work because the typical gt
workflow starts with a table that you
can then
pipe other
arguments to to iteratively add more
layers to your table so we were able to
very quickly once we got acquainted with
the grammar
very quickly generate you know
professional clean looking tables so in
this one you can see a heat map
component added onto it you can also see
the ability to
bold certain things or call attention to
certain rows
you can even add footnotes you could
even add pictures
um from in this case we added pictures
of teams so this was really a huge value
add in terms of our submission
last but not least we made use of shiny
and this was a decision
based upon the fact that i think caitlyn
said this in her presentation it's
important to get buy-in uh from people
and one of the first things that
your audience will want to see is a peek
into your model and your results so we
made the decision to create a shiny app
so that
the audience could for themselves slice
and dice the data and inspect our
results
and
the way
the way this came together was i mean
less than an hour we got this together
and we made use also
of packages that are built on html
widgets so on the left hand side this is
a plotly graph with
crosstalk and on the
right-hand side is a dt table so full
fully interactive table and the magic
here is with crosstalk i think because
you can choose for example to select
just three points from the graph and
when you do it will automatically filter
down that data table so
that was also a really nice
functionality that i think our audience
appreciated
so what we learned and learned is in
quotation marks here because we all work
in data science in a professional
capacity so we were all in
on on the tools that our studio offers
however i think there's like
not a replacement for you know truly tr
stress testing these tools on you know a
timed competition with um really complex
data so
tidy verse and tidy models
really they we saw that it enforced good
methodology and statistical practice and
i think if we were to do it again we
would definitely go with the tidy models
approach just because it takes out a lot
of guesswork and it comes with
really sensible defaults
presentation matters a lot i i really
think that our team didn't do anything
groundbreaking we didn't reinvent the
wheel but i think our
our attention to detail and you know
going the extra step with creating a
shiny app uh really helped um gain a
competitive edge
advanced r book taught us a lot of
efficiency tips and deepened our
knowledge of how certain packages work
particularly per and expose us to new
packages like lemoys so
um
i we
we went through this book together
through r for ds book club so highly
recommend if if you do want to deepen
your knowledge while having fun to join
one of those
github unfortunately is a necessary evil
it was a pain in the ass for for
multiple times but i think we couldn't
have done it without
github
we would like for next time to maybe
create a helper package or two just
because i kind of hinted at this but we
ended up
sourcing a lot of scripts multiple times
and reusing functions multiple times and
they say when you are doing that you
might as well just package it
and
make your life a little more streamlined
and easier
and i think one thing also is
we wanted to make sure that our
presentation
everything that was public facing was as
simple as possible without really
sacrificing complexity
so we really wanted to tailor the
submission to both enthusiasts hobbyists
but also you know the professional
analysts that were that were also
judging the submission
and last but not least designate a
project manager this was really helpful
because this is all something that we
did for fun we weren't getting paid to
do it you know preferably pick someone
that isn't afraid to shoot their shots
into cold dm celebrities online so
um definitely designate a sort of
decision maker in that in that regard
but really i saved the most important
lesson for last if you recall this is
the tweet my first tweet in the
presentation where i was like i don't
understand what any of these events mean
and someone from the r stats community
came to my help and created a cheat
sheet and i think this is just a
tremendous testament to the solidarity
that exists in our community
and maybe the real treasure and the real
lesson is the friends we made along the
way
so with that being said
um i want to thank my teammates um
my role models really honestly
marshall sydney tony and we did it we
won and we'll be back so if you are
participating we'll see you then
thank you
thank you very much for that talk
so that is